imaginez que vous découvrez qu'un de vos
amis très proches est en fait sceptique
et quant au changement climatique quels
contenus sur tout internet lui
recommanderiez vous de regarder à quoi
ressemblerait une vidéo d'utilité
publique sur le changement climatique
quelles sont les caractéristiques d'un
message qui en font un message d'utilité
publique
je crée des contenus de communication
scientifique depuis près de 10 ans
maintenant et j'ai un peu honte de dire
que je n'avais jamais vraiment pris le
temps de me pencher sérieusement sur
cette question et de dresser en
particulier une liste de critères qui
sont importants à considérer pour
chercher à répondre à cette question je
pensais que déterminer si une vidéo et
d'utilité publique était facile et que
vous n'avez donc pas à prendre le temps
d'y réfléchir
mais tout a changé il ya un an lorsqu'un
ingénieur de google m'a contacté il n'a
pas osé essentiellement ces questions
mais à propos du comité 19 en mars 2020
quelles étaient les meilleures vidéos a
recommandé pour clarifier la situation
du comité 19 les risques à venir et la
science de la pandémie et pour appeler
aux actions appropriées étant donné
l'état des connaissances à ce moment ce
qui m'est apparu alors évident à ce
moment c'est le fait qu'une vidéo soit
factuelle ou non est en fait très loin
d'être une considération suffisante pour
déterminer si elle doit être promue à
très grande échelle
bien sûr une vidéo qui aurait comparé le
nombre total de décès dus aux convient
de 19 à celui des décès de la grippe en
mars 2020 aurait été une vidéo
parfaitement factuelle mais il était
aussi clair qu'il ne s'agissait alors
pas d'une vidéo dont la promotion à
grande échelle semblait désirable est ce
parce que les faits ne sont pas toujours
d'utilité publique surtout quand ils
sont sectionnés pour défendre arrêt si
dangereux ou pis encore quand ils sont
sélectionnés pour tromper le public mais
ce n'est pas tout à l'époque les
contenus informatifs et plus fiable sur
le cumul des dix neuf étaient
probablement des conférences université
arthonnais par des virologues ou des
épidémiologistes ou des rapports des
autorités sanitaires comme
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais sans vouloir les offenser ses
contenus étaient aussi relativement
ennuyeux à regarder
- disons pour le grand public de plus il
était souvent surchargés de jargon et de
détails techniques qui n'avait aucun
sens pour la plupart des gens et justes
pour qualifier ce n'est absolument pas
un défaut dans l'absolu t continue
devait être technique car les experts
devaient parler en utilisant des
terminaux g précise et optimisé pour
faciliter la communication entre eux
ainsi pour toutes ces raisons il semble
clair qu'il faut plus que des
informations
bhl pour devenir une vidéo qui devrait
être promu à très grande échelle auprès
de milliards de consommateurs sur
youtube
mais alors que faut-il qu est ce qui
fait d'un message un contenu d'utilité
publique qui devrait être suggérées à
des milliards d'individus
ces questions sont devenues critiques
alors que mes collaborateurs et moi même
mettions en place la plateforme
tournesol en mai 2000 genre tournesol a
pour but d'identifier les meilleures
vidéos d'utilité publique en collectant
le mouvement des contributeurs sur la
qualité des contenus
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter la
liste des critères de qualité que nous
avons élaborée jusqu'à présent pour
aider nos contributeurs à identifier ces
vidéos alors je en fait surtout me
concentrer sur trois critères de qualité
qui sont les trois critères de qualité
par défaut de la plate forme et je ne
mentionnerai que brièvement des six
critères optionnels noter que vous
trouverez plus d'informations et de
ressources concernant ces critères sur
le wiki de tournesol
de plus notre liste actuelle est
probablement encore incomplète et
insatisfaisante et nous serions ravis
d'entendre vos critiques suggestions et
idées d'amélioration
le premier critère de qualité
tournesol a trait à la fiabilité de
l'information ce qui exige généralement
qu'elle soit accompagnée de sources
dignes de confiance
il est évident que les publications
universitaires peuvent être considérés
comme plus fiables mais toutes ces
ressources n'ont pas le même degré de
fiabilité les méta analyse par exemple
le consensus scientifique doivent
généralement être considérés comme plus
fiables même si eux aussi ne doivent pas
être considérés comme une vérité absolue
ceci dit et comme on l'a vu ne suffit
pas qu'un contenu contiennent des
informations factuelles
il doit également être non trompeur et
cela s'avère en fait extrêmement
difficile toute communication se
concentrent généralement sur un aspect
particulier d'un sujet plus vaste mais
en mettant l'accent sur cet aspect
particulier elles peuvent donner une
vision très biaisée de ce qui importe
dans ce sujet typiquement un article sur
l'énergie nucléaire qui traite en détail
de l'accident de tchernobyl peut être
très factuelle et fiable mais il peut
alors laisser au spectateur l'impression
erronée que l'énergie nucléaire qui est
plus dangereuse que d'autres moyens de
produire de l'énergie comme le pétrole
ou le charbon
plus généralement pour éviter d'induire
en erreur il semble important qu'un
contenu fournissent une vue d'ensemble
d'un sujet mais aussi qu'il présente les
différentes théories qui aurait été
proposé pour le comprendre
surtout lorsque le sujet en question est
très controversée en outre pour être
fiables et non trompeur le contenu doit
souligner au mieux les points forts et
les points faibles de toutes les
théories en particulier lorsqu'il existe
différentes théories concurrentes sans
consensus scientifique un message
fiables et non trompeur ne doit pas
présenter uniquement l'interprétation
d'une seule théorie comme s'il
s'agissait de la seule et unique
interprétation possible et ça en fait
c'est vraiment pas facile même en
physique de telles interprétations
double se produisent en fait tout le
temps même lorsqu'il existe un consensus
scientifique typiquement de nombreux
contenus décriront la gravité comme une
force même si la relativité générale ne
décrit pas comme une force si ces
contenus présente une description
entièrement du thonier d'un mécanisme
sans reconnaître explicitement qu'ils
utilisent l'interprétation newtonienne
dont on sait par ailleurs qu'elle est
incorrect alors ces contenus peuvent
être considérés comme légèrement
trompeur
bon après ce ne sera probablement pas
extrêmement trompeurs donc lui en outre
en particulier sur les sujets présentant
une grande incertitude comme le colis
des 19 ans contenu fiable et non trop
peur doit reconnaître voir souligné
toute l'étendue de son ignorance en
particulier les messages qui font preuve
d'une
confiance excessive typiquement
prétendants décrire la vérité alors
qu'il y a une place raisonnable aux
doutes ses contenus doivent être
considérées comme au moins légèrement
trompeur et du coup vous globalement
comme tous les critères ultérieures qui
seront discutés par la suite le critère
fiable et non trompeur est loin d'être
billère et c'est pour cette raison que
tourner au sol a proposé de le juger de
manière comparative
en effet au lieu de demander aux
contributeurs si un contenu est fiable
et non trompeur tournesol demande aux
contributeurs de sélectionner deux
contenus et de dire lequel de ces deux
contenus et plus fiables et non trompeur
le deuxième critère de qualité
tournesol est stimulant et suscite la
réflexion il s'agit évidemment d'un
point essentiel car le message doit
pouvoir capter toute l'attention du
spectateur
surtout s'il vise à communiquer des
informations complexes qui ne pourraient
pas être comprise sans cette attention
la qualité audio visuel d'une vidéo est
évidemment importante pour y parvenir en
particulier les vidéos dont le son est
de mauvaise qualité risque
malheureusement de perdre l'attention du
public
le rythme de la vidéo ainsi que
l'utilisation de l'humour ou des
émotions peuvent également être utile
pour susciter l'intérêt des spectateurs
cependant attiré l'attention des
spectateurs faire bien au delà de ces
éléments audiovisuels l'un des conseils
de veritas yom est de commencer par
l'incroyable qui est essentiel car la
plupart des spectateurs s'arrête après
les premières secondes de visionnage ce
côté incroyable peut être l'image une
expérience incroyable mais ça peut être
aussi une histoire captivante où une
question très intrigante et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'essaie de faire pour
la vidéo que vous êtes en train de
regarder
d'après cette même vidéo de direct le
ton du présentateur est également
essentiel plus généralement si le sait
que certains scientifiques déteste cela
est contenu ont tendance à être beaucoup
plus attrayant
lorsqu'ils sont humaniser typiquement à
travers un présentateur qui est apprécié
de son public ou à travers l'histoire de
héros comme par exemple des grands
scientifiques
bien sûr cela à d'autres inconvénients
vous pourrez nous parlait également de
ses inconvénients
par exemple en termes de fiabilité ou en
termes de la façon dont une telle
présentation peut être trompeuse pour
rendre les contenus encore plus
attrayant il est également utile
d'encourager la participation du
spectateur par exemple via le biais de
sondages sur l'opinion de spectateurs
concernant un dilemme particuliers ou
alors proposant un exercice intéressant
à résoudre ou leur demandant d'envoyer
une vidéo réponse pour expliquer une
observation
beaucoup de gens du monde de l'éducation
vont typiquement valoriser la réflexion
active cela signifie que c'est encore
mieux si l'engagement du spectateur le
conduit à d'autres questions et accro à
sa curiosité
ce sera typiquement le cas si après
avoir consommé le contenu
le spectateur est incité à en discuter
avec ses amis et à rechercher lui-même
plus d'information sur le sujet les
contenus qui se termine par des
questions ouvertes ou par des liens vers
des explications plus complète peuvent
alors être considéré comme étant plus
stimulant et susciter davantage la
réflexion et ça ça peut être en fait
particulièrement important sur des
sujets controversés du moins selon les
études de dan krane et de ses collègues
je ne vais pas vous ré expliquer en
détail leur expérience ici mais en gros
ils ont découvert que les compétences en
mathématiques peuvent anéantir nos
capacités de raisonnement
lorsque la conclusion correct contredit
nos convictions
en fait d'alcan et ses collègues ont
remarqué que les convictions sur le
changement climatique peuvent se
détériorer au fur et à mesure que les
individus s'instruisent mais une
observation intéressante qui l'ont fait
dans une autre étude c'est que la
curiosité scientifique semble
contrecarrer ce phénomène
en effet les individus plus curieux sur
le plan scientifique sont plus d'accord
sur les sujets factuel même lorsque les
conclusions contredisent leur conviction
politique
généralement la volonté d'acquérir des
croyances plus juste y compris lorsque
ces croyances entre en conflit avec les
convictions politiques c'est ce que je
suis de la galette appelle l'état
d'esprit scouts on pourrait traduire
comme le mode explorateurs dans ce tête
toc vu la galère illustrent le mode
explorateurs par l'exemple d'un général
français antisémite qui malgré ses
convictions politiques et c'est énorme
incentive a condamné le suspect juifs
albert dreyfus ce général a réussi à
critiquer ses préjugés à l'égard de
dreyfus à année est soigneusement les
données à sa disposition et a réussi à
conclure correctement que dreyfus
n'était pas coupable
ce mode explorateurs huska août mindset
est aussi le titre du livre de jules
haag et l'efs est sorti récemment et que
je recommande très très très vivement
les contenus qui parvienne à déclencher
le mode explorateur des téléspectateurs
ton des contenus qu'on peut considérer
plus stimulant et susciter davantage si
la réflexion pour cette raison on peut
considérer que ces contenus sont
davantage d'utilité publique
le troisième critère de qualité sur
tournesol est appelée important et
suscite la réflexion
ils demandent dans quelle mesure le
sujet abordé par un message est
prioritaire et dans quelle mesure il est
crucial qu'un large public soit exposée
au message ce problème était
particulièrement important dans les
premiers jours de la pandémie de kobe de
19 ou un énorme torrent d'informations
envahissait les réseaux sociaux
malheureusement à ce moment là l'accent
a parfois été mis beaucoup trop sur des
aspects secondaires comme par exemple
l'origine d'une copie de 10,9 dont il
était sans doute moins important de
parler que des mesures barrières
efficaces pour ralentir la pandémie
comme rester chez soi éviter les
contacts physiques et ventiler les zones
fermées
autre exemple lorsqu'il s'agit
d'atténuer le changement climatique
demandé aux spectateurs d'éteindre la
lumière lorsqu'il ne sont pas chez eux
est en fait beaucoup beaucoup moins
important que par exemple éviter de
prendre l'avion vers des pays lointains
un contenu qui mettraient trop l'accent
sur le premier pourrait ainsi être
considérés comme moins important qu'un
contenu qui traite du second est un
contenu qui serait mieux encore serait
peut-être un contenu qui explique en
quoi le second est bien plus important
que le premier
l'importance d'un sujet semble
étroitement liée à l'ampleur du problème
et à la taille des faits des
interventions potentiel en particulier
si une intervention modeste est tout à
fait réalisable peut améliorer de
manière significative le bien-être d'un
très grand nombre d'individus avec une
forte probabilité alors tout message qui
parlent de cette intervention devrait
sans doute avoir beaucoup d'attention un
tel contenu pourra être considéré très
important et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que tournesol s'intéresse autant
aux algorithmes de recommandations de
contenu ces algorithmes influence
quotidiennement les croyances et les
habitudes de milliards d'individus
ce qui a ensuite des conséquences
majeures sur la politique la santé
publique et la sécurité nationale
pourtant il suffirait de légèrement
modifier ses algorythmes pour améliorer
considérablement l'information du public
ce qui permettrait par exemple d'adressé
le changement climatique et le contrôle
des pandémies de manière beaucoup
beaucoup plus efficace en favorisant les
informations importantes tournesol
espère notamment lutter contre le
problème majeur des doutes news c'est
mieux de nous ou nouvelle rendue
silencieuses sont des messages qu'il
traite de données ou d'idées extrêmement
importante et exploitables mais qui
n'obtiennent pas l'intention qu'elle
devrait avoir parce qu'elles sont
volontairement ou involontairement noyé
dans un océan d'enfants
beaucoup moins pertinente
bien sûr il y aurait beaucoup
c'est à dire sur les différents critères
de qualité choisie par tourner au sol
sur leur pertinence et surtout sur leurs
limites pour combler ses limites
tournesol permet aux contributeurs de
noter d'autres critères de qualité dit
optionnel
malheureusement pour ne pas rendre cette
vidéo trop longue je ne présenterai que
succinctement les critères de qualité
optionnel le quatrième critère de
cliquer du tournesol est de savoir si un
contenu encourage de meilleures
habitudes il peut le faire d'ailleurs de
manière explicite ou implicite ses
meilleures habitudes peuvent
correspondre à des habitudes plus saines
par exemple en termes d'alimentation
d'activités sportives de santé mentale
ou d'une attention plus attentive à la
qualité de l'information à laquelle on
est exposé il peut également s'agir d'
habitude meilleur pour la société en
général comme le fait d'être plus
bienveillants envers les autres y
compris sur internet de réduire notre
empreinte carbone et de nous méfier de
notre excès de confiance
le cinquième critère de qualité consiste
à déterminer si un contenu est claire et
pédagogique en particulier accompagne
t-il le processus de réflexion du
spectateur et le conduit-il
soigneusement étape par étape à travers
un raisonnement potentiellement
complexes en particulier le contenu
corrige y'at-il les idées fausses et
plus probable du spectateur fait-il
preuve suffisamment d'empathie cognitive
le sixième critères de qualité et
accessibles aux non spécialistes
il s'agit de savoir si le contenu
convient à des personnes qui ne
connaissait pratiquement rien au sujet
traité un enfant de 5 ans comprendre est
il ce qui est dit alors vous pouvez
penser que c'est la même chose que
claire et pédagogique une aux données
actuelles montrent que ces deux
considérations de son presque
orthogonale selon les jugements de nos
contributeurs
le prototype d'un contenu pédagogique
qui n'est pas facilement accessible et
l'une des nombreuses vidéos de futures
bornes par exemple l'excellente vidéo
sur règles de bale écrite avec décote
le septième critères de qualité sur tout
le sol est diversité et inclusion
nous pensons que ce critère est
essentielle pour attirer une grande
variété de profils et de points de vue
et pour éviter en particulier le
problème des angles morts
c'est particulièrement le cas pour les
sujets où il existe un biais historiques
importants comme par exemple
l'informatique qui est malheureusement
actuellement dominé par certaines sous
population plutôt que d'autres 8e
critères de qualité est résilient retour
de flamme
ce critère est particulièrement crucial
pour les sujets controversés le contenu
offensant sera-t-il certains spectateurs
va-t-il créer une méfiance exacerbée
chez ceux dont les croyants sont remises
en question par le contenu amènera-t-il
les opposants à m
venir davantage de mauvaise foi
malheureusement de nombreuses études
estiment que ce sera le cas pour la
plupart des contenus qui peuvent
renforcer chaque côté d'un débat dans
leur propre croyance typiquement une
étude de 2018 a montré que les
utilisateurs de twitter qui se sont mis
à suivre un bot qui réduit
automatiquement les tués étaient de
l'autre camp politique
ses utilisateurs en fait renforcer leur
attachement à leur propre camp ainsi que
leur haine du camp opposé tournesol vise
à identifier les contenus qu'ils ont
moins de chance de conduire à de tels
résultats indésirables
enfin le neuvième critères de qualité
est divertissant et relaxant de toute
évidence
youtube est parfois consommés par des
spectateurs quelque peu fatigué auquel
cas ils peuvent préférer un contenu qui
n'est pas trop exigeant sur le plan
cognitif
voilà vous connaissez maintenant les
neuf critères de qualité retenue jusqu'à
présent sur tournesol alors modifier les
critères actuels c'est un peu difficile
puisque ça va compliquer l'analyse des
données dont on a déjà à disposition
ceci étant dit nous sommes tout à fait
disposés à mettre à jour la plate forme
si le besoin se fait vraiment sentir ce
qui nous importe le plus sur tournesol
c'est de collecter la meilleure base de
données possible pour ensuite faciliter
la recherche sur les tic de la
recommandation de contenu donc si vous
avez des propositions d'amélioration de
notre liste ne seront plus que ravis de
les entendre en particulier faites-nous
savoir s'il ya un critère de qualité
important qui n'est pas prise en compte
parce que nous avons jusqu'à présent et
qui devrait donc être rajouté un autre
liste pour réussir à bien identifier de
potentiels critères je vous encourage
vivement à aller noté des vidéos sur
tournesol d'expériences personnelles
ceci est beaucoup à mieux se rendre
compte de ce que ces critères présente
dans des cas concrets et ça à titre
personnel ça m'a amené à beaucoup de
réflexions intéressantes et je sais que
c'est aussi l'expérience d'autres
contributeurs sur tournesol en
particulier après avoir noté des vidéos
demandez vous s'il ya quelque chose que
vous aimeriez dire à ce sujet de cette
vidéo que vous n'avez pas réussi à dire
à travers les différents critères
bref si vous voulez vraiment et des
tournesols à mieux adresser l'éthique de
la recommandation du contenu je vous
invite vivement à aller sur la
plateforme tournesol points ap
à télécharger nos extension google
chrome et firefox ou à utiliser notre
application sur android et via ces
outils a jugé un grand nombre de vidéos
youtube tournesol vous en sera
extrêmement reconnaissants